welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday Boston is a mecca of higher
education home to idyllic campuses elite
universities like Harvard and MIT it is
also where city and community leaders
are engaged in a bold experiment to use
higher education to transform the city's
most dangerous neighborhoods less than
2% of the city's youth are involved in
gangs but they are responsible for
nearly three-quarters of the shootings
on just five percent of the city's
street corners the program Boston uncor
nerd recruits these gang members even
paying them $400 a week to drop their
guns and enroll in school
supporters say it costs less than the
ongoing cycle of enforcement
incarceration and recidivism and is also
an investment in the community 33
year-old Antonio Franklin is studying
sociology at Boston's Bunker Hill
Community College how hard has school
been for you the last couple years hard
juggling in school with my family very
odd but when you buy you something if
you wanted that died you're gonna push
yourself to get to get to what you want
Bunker Hill is only seven miles but a
world away from the Dorchester
neighborhood where Franklin grew up he's
there on a scholarship of sorts part of
a program that gives former gang members
money to stay in school some people may
look at this and they'll say this was a
guy he wasn't a gang why should we
reward him by paying him to go to school
now I would say no we're not being paid
really to go to school I appreciate the
money it keeps us from detour and off of
our perfect gives us a little bit of
help getting in this program it gave me
a second chance the game yet another
opportunity to live my life Franklin
started getting involved with gangs
around the age of 13 what were some of
the things that you got involved in well
you know I got involved with you know
selling drugs I got involved with Street
stuff I got fights I've been stabbed
shot three times you know I've been to a
lot the game caught up with him in 2007
the cop was shot you know it was my
action as I caused the reaction he was
shot
his own partner and I ended up getting 9
to 10 years for it but Franklin's life
would change at his sentencing thanks to
what that wounded officer said he wanted
me to go in there he wanted me to change
for the better better meant myself and
to hate I coming from a police officer
especially a police office that I was a
victim of my actions it really was a
change of heart he'd served 10 years
before his release he got his GED did
you know what would await you when you
got out no that's the most scariest
thing a friend put Franklin in touch
with Francisco de pinna de pinna is a
college readiness advisor like Franklin
he's also a former gang member from
Dorchester my great teacher told me he
said by the time you're 18 either gonna
be dead or in jail I can't at that time
I kind of believed it I thought that was
my path I just brushed it off and said
oh whatever but then when you know
school wasn't for me no more and I was
hanging out on the street I was stuck in
that corner one day a recruiter reached
out from the local nonprofit
college-bound Dorchester and asked apena
to take some classes what did you think
when he said that to you school is not
for me and he didn't give up on me and
eventually I said you know what I'll try
college-bound Dorchester helped Depina
get his GED he's paying them back all
right
by helping to recruit others into the
program obviously it doesn't work the
first time it might not work the second
it might not even work at a time the key
to being a recruiter and doing this work
it's not you can always go back try
again why don't you give up
because someone didn't give up on me so
I'm not going to you de pinna is now one
of 15 recruiters who college-bound
founder mark colleton considers core
influencers for the organization's three
year old program boston uncor nerd the
strange thing is that I believe it's
gang leaders and only gang leaders that
can actually transform communities why
is that they're so disproportionately
powerful but that power can be harnessed
for good I think the one unconventional
thing that people find is you're going
to pay someone who's in a gang been in a
gang to go to school right it would be
great if everybody could do exactly the
right thing all the time
none of us do that when you offer them a
different opportunity and you say we
will invest in you to make different
choices they're desperate to do that
they want a way out they just need an
excuse and an opportunity Carlton can
relate having made poor choices as a
teenager after his parents divorce I
immediately sort of fell off the cliff
started selling drugs breaking into
houses like just sort of went wild yeah
and I would get arrested and my
college-educated white mother would come
down to the police station and like make
the police apologize to me and send me
home
he says the philosophy behind the
program Boston nun cornered is based on
three core principles hire former gang
members there's different scholarships
out there you want to try to get you
insist on high expectations from
students and invest in their future in
other words don't be afraid to put your
money where your mouth is to give these
leaders an opportunity to make positive
choices and if you just do those three
simple things your city will change what
did you think when you first heard about
it I said it's about time Boston Police
Commissioner William grass the first
african-american to lead his force sees
this as an extension of the department's
community policing enacted citywide we
want to reach the individuals that are
having challenges and then help them out
so you actually pay in the gang
remember or are you paying Spain a
future right so you say gang's right we
pay for the lawyers incarceration the
upkeep no this is an investment into
someone's future to change their life
for the better and it'll be a return
investment for us the community like
Antonio Franklin using the investment
made in him to lay a foundation for his
future and his families you have a
two-year-old yes what does this program
mean in terms of him an example you're
able to set for him a role model it
shows that you know I don't want my son
to look back on my life
Google me and see that oh my father was
just somebody who was in the streets I
wanted to see that my father you know he
was in the streets but he came home and
he really did good and I just do good he
did good for the betterment of everybody
around him that's who I want to be an
Antonia wants to use the degree when he
gets it to start a youth program and
help others this is the whole idea
behind Boston on cornered one Domino at
a time Antonio knew Francisco in the
neighborhood they were both in the gang
he gets out he sees that he's doing
better hey maybe I can do this you need
that leg up you need the help Marc talk
to us about the name everyone has been
cornered in at some point and everyone
needs help to get out of that corner and
that's behind Boswell and that's the
more important part of it though is not
just doing it for yourself doing it for
the next generation and doing it for the
kids so they can say like what what was
daddy what was mommy yeah and they do
and they they point out also the cost of
incarceration and repeated incarceration
is more than what is being invested in
these people each year and that's
something to consider as well here's to
Marc and chief Willy I like that because
everyone behind that program